Like, I think my take on events these days is just like the agentic area has made open-ended judging a bit cooked because it's like, how do you tell whether something is amazing versus not if it's just like if Claude once shot it? But if someone did a hill climb on a task that we can all collectively agree on is hard and made like a breakthrough, that's better than what I would do myself as like an advanced user. Like if they can just do that during the Akathon, like I'm very impressed. And so like, it just doesn't matter how they did it. It matters the output. So I think that I'm very open to. And I think it's going to become a lot more interesting doing it with open models this year because the open models are good finally at these tests.
我觉得如今我对这些事件的看法是，智能体时代让开放式评判变得有点复杂，因为如果 Claude 一次性就完成了，你怎么判断某件事是好是坏？但如果有人针对我们公认的难题进行了爬山算法并取得了突破，那比我作为一个高级用户自己做的要好。如果他们能在黑客松期间做到这一点，我会非常佩服。所以，他们是怎么做到的并不重要，重要的是产出。所以我对此持非常开放的态度。而且我认为今年使用开源模型来做这件事会变得更有趣，因为开源模型终于在这些测试中表现出色了。
I think it looks like they've been RLed on kernel data. And so I think it's going to be a lot more exciting than it was like a year ago. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 304, recorded on July 20th, 2006. My name is Connor. And today with my co-host, Price, we finish part three of our three-part conversation with Mark Serafam. In this episode, we continue our conversation about GPU mode, auto research, Mark's favorite books, and more.
我认为看起来它们已经在内核数据上进行了强化学习。所以我认为这会比一年前令人兴奋得多。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客，第 304 期，录制于 2006 年 7 月 20 日。我是 Connor。今天，我和我的联合主持人 Price 一起，完成了我们与 Mark Serafam 三部分对话的第三部分。在这一集中，我们将继续讨论 GPU 模式、自动研究、Mark 最喜欢的书籍等等。
The thing that really influenced me on this was one of the first things I did, and this was back in March, April, with Opus 4.7, which feels like a long time ago, was like auto research on cub's histogram. And that auto research, I didn't give it any steering. And it basically, that auto research popped out six different relatively novel algorithms two of them were like kind of existing, a twist on existing techniques, but the rest were like really kind of, I think, novel. They did build on like existing things from literature. This is the S-MM-Cash that Connor that we talked about in the last episode. Like certainly like caches, hash tables are like a thing that are in literature. And I think there of, you know, histograms are very similar to, to a hash table in some way.
真正影响我的是我做的第一件事，那是在三四月份，用 Opus 4.7，感觉是很久以前的事了，当时是对 Cub 的直方图进行自动研究。在那次自动研究中，我没有给它任何引导。基本上，那次自动研究产生了六种相对新颖的算法，其中两种算是现有技术的变体，但其余的我认为确实非常新颖。它们确实建立在文献中现有事物的基础上。这就是我们在上一集中讨论的 S-MM-Cash。当然，缓存和哈希表是文献中存在的东西。我认为直方图在某种程度上与哈希表非常相似。
So, you know, maybe there is actually some literature out there on this, particularly. technique, but it really did feel like it was a novel, it wasn't a completely novel idea, but it was a novel combination of ideas. And there was no chance I would have ever come up with that idea on my own. Yeah. I guess, I'm curious to ask you on this specific example, like, what was, what was it like trying to merge it back into Cup? I don't, because I don't know if you did it right now. I'm in the process doing that right now. So the interesting thing with that, with the cub histogram was the key like auto research run
所以，也许确实有一些关于这种特定技术的文献，但它确实感觉像是一个新颖的想法，虽然不是完全原创，但它是想法的新颖组合。我绝对不可能自己想出那个主意。是的。我想问你关于这个具体例子的问题，尝试把它合并回 Cub 是什么样的体验？我不知道你现在是否做到了。我正在处理这个过程。关于 Cub 直方图，有趣的是自动研究运行
was done in like I think the last auto research run I did for that was like end of May and so I came out of that with like the candidate code in kernels and what I've had to do since then is I was running auto research with
是在我记得我为它做的最后一次自动研究运行中完成的，大概是五月底，所以我从中得到了候选代码和内核，从那以后我必须做的是，我一直在用
Cubs existing benchmark which handles which has basically like two different distributions and you know I knew I needed to do a much wider input characterization. So I constructed a whole lot more inputs. I constructed adversarial inputs. Me and the agent learned that in fact, the way that Cobb generated its histogram inputs for the benchmark have always been broken since the beginning of time. And the full like input characterization takes like
Cub 现有的基准测试进行自动研究，它基本上处理了两种不同的分布，我知道我需要进行更广泛的输入表征。所以我构建了更多的输入。我构建了对抗性输入。我和智能体了解到，事实上，Cub 为基准测试生成直方图输入的方式从一开始就是坏的。完整的输入表征在 B200 上需要大约
30 hours on a B200 to like really get good data. And with Cobb, there's the constraint that we really can't ship six different algorithms, one for this particular dynamic shape, one for that particular dynamic shape. And so I've done more like manual work. How come, by the way? Like was it because it's sort of a binary size? Yeah, yeah, yeah. So I needed really to pick, like, I was going to have to go with two algorithms, one for the small bin case and one for the large bin case. And there are a couple of like additional post-auto research optimizations that me and the agent did. And those things were basically, they weren't new algorithms. It was just like the right
30 个小时才能真正获得好的数据。对于 Cub，有一个限制，我们真的不能发布六种不同的算法，一种用于这种特定的动态形状，另一种用于那种特定的动态形状。所以我做了更多的人工工作。顺便问一下，为什么？是因为二进制大小吗？是的，是的。所以我真的需要选择，我不得不使用两种算法，一种用于小分箱情况，另一种用于大分箱情况。我和智能体还做了一些自动研究后的额外优化。这些东西基本上不是新算法。它只是
combination of things, like combining the S-M-Cash with the existing privatized, you know, histograms in global memory. And then like, at one point, we turned off warp coalescing before you hit the S-M-Cash was like a big loss. But doing coalescing on spills from the cash was a big win. and like I just got it sort of nailed down and I've looked at the code a few times throughout this process I think there's two things I can try the first thing is I can try to run my simplify
事物的组合，比如将 S-M-Cash 与现有的全局内存中的私有化直方图相结合。然后，在某个时候，我们在进入 S-M-Cash 之前关闭了线程束合并，这是一个巨大的损失。但在缓存溢出时进行合并是一个巨大的胜利。我刚刚把它搞定了，在这个过程中我看了几次代码，我想我可以尝试两件事，第一件事是我可以尝试运行我的简化
skill and the simplify skill is basically minimize the bytes of code difference of non-common code difference from upstream the alternative I think would be to identify like a series of commits of like okay this is like the cue's like four PR we could break this down into four PRs
技能，简化技能基本上是最小化与上游代码相比非公共代码的字节差异。我认为另一种选择是确定一系列提交，比如，好的，这是 Cub 的四个 PR，我们可以将其分解为四个 PR
and let's let's just do the four PRs as like from Fresh. Like don't try to take the existing code and like reshape it into a PR, but just like using the existing code as a reference point, generate the PRs. And I think those PRs are going to go up sometime this month. And my guess is going to be that it will take two months or so to merge. I think it's in a shape now where it will be acceptable. Yeah, I mean the current code is,
让我们把这四个 PR 当作全新的来做。不要试图拿现有的代码并将其重塑为 PR，而是以现有代码为参考点来生成 PR。我认为这些 PR 将在这个月内提交。我的猜测是合并大约需要两个月左右。我认为它现在的形状是可以接受的。是的，我的意思是当前的代码是
it's a little bit of a mess. Like the single biggest problem was not following conventions in the code base. So like there was a convention for how tuning got done and it wasn't followed. And a good part of it was things that the model never could have known. For example, like, oh, you know, this is the way that we used to do the tuning in this part of code. But, you know, there's a new policy that's not documented anywhere for how we would do this. But the PR probably won't be accepted if it doesn't follow this new convention. Or like, there's, you know, there's this convention that we, if you want to have an algorithm that dynamically dispatches to, if you want to have a cub routine that can dynamically dispatches to two algorithms, like, we need to get a special sign off from someone.
有点乱。最大的问题是没有遵循代码库中的约定。比如，关于如何进行调优有一个约定，但没有被遵循。其中很大一部分是模型永远无法知道的事情。例如，哦，你知道，这是我们过去在代码这部分进行调优的方式。但是，你知道，有一个新的政策，没有任何文档记录我们应该如何做。但是，如果 PR 不遵循这个新约定，它可能不会被接受。或者，你知道，有这样一个约定，如果你想拥有一个可以动态分发到两种算法的算法，如果你想拥有一个可以动态分发到两种算法的 Cub 例程，我们需要获得某人的特别签字。
And that's not documented in the code. So how, how could the model have ever known that? This is interesting. Like, basically, the, this sort of makes sense if you sort of assume, like, this is my guess, by the way, that like the cup team has been working on it for a while, that the original team hasn't. disbanded much. And so a lot of these sort of like unwritten rules are actually in people's heads and they all have internalized them and there's no reason to write docs because maybe the team doesn't grow very quickly. But then like in an age where you're forcing them to verbalize everything. They're like, oh, God damn it. Like this is so much work. I have to write docs now and have to write tests. Yeah. Yeah. I see it interesting. Yeah. But I think it will be very interesting to see whether we can get this landed because Cobb in particular is a really high barrier to land because
而这在代码中没有记录。那么模型怎么可能知道呢？这很有趣。基本上，如果你假设，这是我的猜测，Cub 团队已经工作了一段时间，原始团队没有解散太多。所以很多这种不成文的规则实际上都在人们的脑子里，他们都内化了这些规则，没有理由写文档，因为也许团队增长得并不快。但后来，在一个你强迫他们把一切都口头表达出来的时代。他们会说，哦，该死。这工作量太大了。我现在必须写文档，还必须写测试。是的。是的，我明白了，很有趣。是的。但我认为看看我们是否能让它落地会非常有趣，因为 Cub 特别难以落地，因为
you need to be good across a really wide range of inputs and, you know, you can't like ignore edge cases. And so it'll be, I'm hopeful because I do think it's a, it's like a pretty big win for the, for the cases that it, like now I've gotten it to the point where essentially there's, there's no adversarial inputs that are really bad for it. There may be one left. I got to try that. Yeah. Have you done any auto research work that has landed upstream PRs and big projects that have a high bar for quality? Personally, no. I think around the time I left meta, there was like, I think an art, like a fused RMS norm, which was like the first AI generated kernel that was merged. But that was like not my work. That was like Laura, Laura's work on the kernel agent team. I do remember, though, the main experience we had at the time was that like the colonel was quite long. And so I think it was important to deslapify it.
你需要在一系列非常广泛的输入中表现良好，而且你不能忽略边缘情况。所以我很抱歉，因为我确实认为这是一个很大的胜利，对于那些情况，现在我已经把它做到了基本上没有对它非常糟糕的对抗性输入。可能还剩下一个。我得试试那个。是的。你做过任何自动研究工作，并成功将 PR 合并到对质量要求很高的重大项目中吗？就我个人而言，没有。我想在我离开 Meta 的时候，有一个融合的 RMS 范数，那是第一个被合并的 AI 生成的内核。但那不是我的工作。那是 Laura 在内核智能体团队的工作。不过我确实记得，当时我们的主要经验是内核相当长。所以我认为简化它很重要。
I think there was sometimes a bit of an ideological debate between like, what's the point of deslopifying it? Like, just don't need it. To which, like, the Pytrarch core maintainers were like, what are you talking about? Because this is maintenance of that I need to understand every single line. I'm not sure which of those two stances is correct because, like, some of those Pitech people who felt very strongly by these things are just like no longer working on the team. And so, like, I actually don't know.
我认为有时在“简化它的意义是什么？”之间存在一点意识形态上的争论。比如，根本不需要。对此，PyTorch 核心维护者说，你在说什么？因为这是我需要理解每一行的维护工作。我不确定这两种立场中哪一个是正确的，因为一些对这些事情感觉非常强烈的 PyTorch 人员已经不再在团队中工作了。所以，我实际上不知道。
But kind of like one thing that stands out to me at least was like this one I think this is sort of a paraphrase from a talk by Terrance Tao So it's not exactly what he said but it's like what I came away with Which is that like he was sort of talking about like I mean let me just not that I'll just talk about kernels Like basically like my hypothesis is that typically by the time you're done writing a complicated kernel You already have simplified it multiple times because as you're writing something you're like evolving it you're fixing it And you've also like understood it. Like by the end of it, if you sort of like artisanly crafted something,
但有一件事至少对我来说很突出，我想这是对 Terence Tao 的一次演讲的转述，所以这不完全是他说的，但这是我的收获，那就是他谈论的是，我的意思是，让我不要谈论这个，我只谈论内核。基本上，我的假设是，通常当你写完一个复杂的内核时，你已经多次简化了它，因为当你写东西时，你是在进化它，你在修复它，而且你也理解了它。到最后，如果你像工匠一样精心制作了某样东西，
basically generating, understanding, simplifying is like in some sense the same act. But like if we're in an age where people are only doing generation, it becomes like I think a bit of a problem because like let's say your colonel introduces a race condition, but it's like non-deterministic. Well, you know, that really sucks for a model training run. But maybe it's forgivable for like a tiny little inference service that like runs some sort of speculative optimization. So there's like a risk-reward thing where like maybe there's some areas where
基本上生成、理解、简化在某种意义上是同一个行为。但如果我们处于一个人们只做生成的时代，这就会成为一个问题，因为假设你的内核引入了一个竞争条件，但它是非确定性的。好吧，你知道，这对模型训练运行来说真的很糟糕。但也许对于某种运行某种投机优化的微小推理服务来说是可以原谅的。所以存在一种风险回报权衡，也许在某些领域
it need to be really paranoid and this is not acceptable. But generally, like when I broadly look at this, I just don't buy the people don't care because, you know, as we talked at the beginning of this episode on like, if people are freaked out about non-determinism, like, boy, are they going to be freaked out about like straight up in correctness books that are like non-deterministic as well. Like I think this is bound to cause conspiracy theories, especially at scale, right? Like if let's say 1% of your users only see something like that. So my broad take is like, I think we should solve the hard problem.
需要非常谨慎，这是不可接受的。但总的来说，当我广泛地看待这个问题时，我不相信人们不在乎，因为正如我们在本集开头讨论的那样，如果人们对非确定性感到恐慌，那么，天哪，他们会对那些同样是非确定性的直接不正确的错误感到恐慌。我认为这必然会导致阴谋论，特别是在规模化的情况下，对吧？比如，假设 1% 的用户只看到类似的东西。所以我的总体看法是，我认为我们应该解决这个难题。
I don't think the solution is people are reading the code. That to me feels like, like, no, like, because let's say the QR problem. You know, at first I was like, hey, I'm going to sort of synthesize all the kernels by all 170 users. And I'm going to try to come up with like a beautiful QR kernel. You know, like I've yet to do this. It feels onerous every time I think about like sitting down and doing this exercise. but at the same time, if I just ask it at Kodak, and I'm like, hey, Godex, go, go, go, X, go, look at all these kernels and tell me what comes up.
我不认为解决方案是人们在阅读代码。这对我来说感觉不对，因为假设是 QR 问题。起初我想，嘿，我要合成所有 170 个用户的内核。我要尝试想出一个漂亮的 QR 内核。你知道，我还没有这样做。每次想到坐下来做这个练习，都觉得很繁重。但与此同时，如果我只是问它，嘿，Kodak，去，去，去，X，去，看看所有这些内核，告诉我出现了什么。
In some sense, I don't even know, did it read everything? Did it, like, really understand, like, everything? Did it capture the key ideas? Like, maybe there's a slow kernel that had more elegant ideas. Will it really capture them or will really just prioritize the first, like, dozen kernels that are fast? Like, I'm not sure. Like, in some sense, like, I don't know what the model is doing.
在某种意义上，我甚至不知道，它读了所有东西吗？它真的理解了一切吗？它捕捉到了关键思想吗？也许有一个缓慢的内核有更优雅的想法。它真的会捕捉到它们，还是真的只会优先考虑前十几个快速的内核？我不确定。在某种意义上，我不知道模型在做什么。
Like, I can't inspect it. Like, so it does feel like it's an alien artifact. I tell it, go cook. but my hope is that we can sort of figure out how to come up with beautiful kernels from a large sum of fast but slop kernels. I just think like it's maybe in the beginning there's a bit more manual than we'd like,
我无法检查它。所以它确实感觉像是一个外星文物。我告诉它，去煮。但我的希望是，我们可以弄清楚如何从大量快速但草率的内核中想出漂亮的内核。我只是认为也许在开始时比我们想要的更手动一些，
but I'm fairly confident we can figure out good tooling for problems like this. So first of all, I gotta say, I find it very interesting, the proposition that a race condition, slightly buggy kernel that's like good 99% of the time, but in really fast. Maybe it's good enough in some cases. I didn't consider that before. Maybe it is. For inferences. So my goal in auto research here is to think about what's the process that I as a human would do. And I think that both
但我相当有信心我们可以为这类问题找出好的工具。首先，我必须说，我发现这个命题非常有趣，即一个竞争条件、稍微有点问题的内核，99% 的时间是好的，但速度非常快。也许在某些情况下这就足够了。我以前没考虑过。也许是这样。对于推理。所以我在自动研究中的目标是思考我作为一个人类会采取什么过程。我认为无论是
for humans and agents, it's very hard to optimize for multiple things at once. And every time that I've had to myself do like deep like kernel performance work, it's, almost always where I have a phase where I'm trying to reach speed of light. And during that phase, you know, I'm adding restrict places. I'm adding in assumes. I'm adding in this and that. I'm re-benchmarking. I'm trying things. I'm if-deffing stuff out. You know, I've got some dead code branches, et cetera. And then like, and then I reach performance. And I'm like, oh, great. This is the right thing. And then I've got this mess. And then what I do is, I go back and I'm like, okay, I'm going to delete all the if-defs.
对于人类还是智能体，同时优化多件事是非常困难的。每当我不得不自己进行深入的内核性能工作时，几乎总是我有一个试图达到光速的阶段。在这个阶段，你知道，我正在添加限制位置。我正在添加假设。我正在添加这个和那个。我正在重新进行基准测试。我正在尝试各种东西。我正在进行 if-def。你知道，我有一些死代码分支等等。然后，我达到了性能。然后我想，哦，太棒了。这是正确的事情。然后我得到了这个烂摊子。然后我所做的是，我回去，我想，好的，我要删除所有的 if-defs。
I'm going to, you know, take out those, like, if I take out this as soon, is it fine? Okay. And, you know, and then I've always got like four versions of this code. And it's like, okay, well, like, I can delete this variant that I don't need anymore. And I can leave that variant. And it's like, I always do this process where I've first spent a bunch of time trying to find speed of light.
我要，你知道，取出那些，如果我取出这个假设，可以吗？好的，而且，你知道，我总是有四个版本的代码。这就像，好的，好吧，我可以删除我不再需要的那个变体。我可以留下那个变体。这就像，我总是做这个过程，我先花了很多时间试图找到光速。
And then once you've found speed of light, then, like, you have an Oracle answer. And then I can try to write. better, cleaner versions. And so I think it's, to me, it is like a natural process to do this V-shaped thing, or maybe not V, or upside-down V, where like you're climbing up to find the fast thing, and then like you're climbing down to make it not so ugly. And I think one of the, you know, maybe I'm wrong about this idea that you, or I said that like you can't always optimize for two things at once. It's harder to optimize for multiple things, harder to optimize for multiple things, It's harder to opt us from multiple things.
然后一旦你找到了光速，那么，你就有了一个 Oracle 答案。然后我可以尝试写出更好、更干净的版本。所以对我来说，这就像一个自然的过程，做这个 V 形的事情，或者也许不是 V，或者倒 V，就像你在爬上去寻找快的东西，然后你在爬下来让它不那么丑。我认为其中一个，也许我对你不能总是同时优化两件事的想法是错的，或者我说过你不能总是同时优化两件事。优化多件事更难，优化多件事更难，优化多件事更难。
And I think that's true, but I think part of that is just that we don't have the right reward metrics and safeguards in place. To me, if my auto research process always generating these like 10,000 line, you know, slop things that's got all this dead code over, that to me means I haven't put the right guardrails in place. I haven't put the right linters and the right things for code quality. and if I did more of that, then I could probably generate a better kernels. And also, I think that would help with the stalls. And yeah, not everything can be like deterministically checked or machine checked. The other thing is like I, so right now I have in my framework, you know, the model can go off. I let it, it can do a macro optimization, a micro optimization, and then a combine.
我认为这是真的，但我认为部分原因只是我们没有正确的奖励指标和保障措施。对我来说，如果我的自动研究过程总是生成这些 10,000 行的、你知道，草率的东西，上面有所有这些死代码，那对我来说意味着我没有把正确的护栏放在适当的位置。我没有把正确的 linter 和正确的代码质量的东西放在适当的位置。如果我做了更多那样的事情，那么我可能就能生成更好的内核。而且，我认为这也会有助于解决停滞问题。是的，并非所有事情都可以确定性地检查或机器检查。另一件事是，所以现在我在我的框架中，你知道，模型可以离开。我让它，它可以做一个宏优化，一个微优化，然后是一个组合。
And I do have a fourth type called Simplify. and usually I don't let it run simplified during the main auto research loop but maybe I should. Maybe it should be simplifying as it goes. The reason I set it up this way is that I've, I guess I've always done some of the simplification as I go but usually I make a mess of things
我确实有一种第四种类型叫简化。通常我不让它在主自动研究循环中运行简化，但也许我应该。也许它应该在进行时进行简化。我这样设置的原因是，我，我想我一直在进行时做一些简化，但通常我把事情搞得一团糟
until I find speed of light. Yeah, it's interesting like your harness is like your own process. Yeah. Yeah. I'm not sure. Like I think it's hard for me to say this is right or wrong. Like this seems like much more of a like personal choice.
直到我找到光速。是的，这很有趣，你的工具就像你自己的过程。是的。是的。我不确定。我认为对我来说很难说这是对还是错。这看起来更像是一个个人选择。
So I can see argument, good arguments being made either way. Yeah, yeah. So, yeah, I find, I find the, the, the mission that, that you guys have at core automation is very complying to me, because, like, it seems, it seems very evident that, like, if you can make the model really good at automating the development of the model, then, like, you can, like, then it can do all the rest, right?
所以我可以看到双方都有很好的论据。是的，是的。所以，是的，我发现，你们在核心自动化所做的使命对我来说非常令人信服，因为，看起来很明显，如果你能让模型非常擅长自动化模型的开发，那么，它就可以做剩下的所有事情，对吧？
You can just sit back and sip tea. Oh, yeah. I mean, like, what's cool about it, it too is that like I again because like for me this is all new but like by virtue of focusing on like on a few problems I think it simplifies like a lot of things like you know we don't have to have like a model that's like necessarily generally capable at all sorts of things but it primarily needs to be good at things that are tasks in the lab so like you can think of every individual person in the lab is like an eval in some sense yeah and I think this is like very helpful framing
你可以坐下来喝茶。哦，是的。我的意思是，它酷的地方在于，我再次因为对我来说这一切都是新的，但通过专注于几个问题，我认为它简化了很多事情，你知道，我们不必拥有一个在各种事情上都普遍有能力的模型，但它主要需要擅长实验室中的任务，所以你可以认为实验室中的每个人在某种意义上都是一个评估。是的，我认为这是一个非常有帮助的框架
that you know when you look at like the kinds of tasks people do in the lab like it just it becomes very self-evident, like, how you should do the rest, that, like, let's say for kernels at least, like, none of the evils I know of open source, and I know this because I've also created a couple of them are, like, sufficient for what we want. And then it's, like, very cool thinking through, like, basically, like, how do you, like, basically what would, you know,
你知道，当你观察人们在实验室里做的各种任务时，它就变得非常不言自明，你应该如何做剩下的事情，至少对于内核来说，我所知道的开源评估中没有一个是足够的，我知道这一点是因为我也创建了其中的几个。然后，思考一下，基本上，什么会，你知道，
the way I explain this to my colleagues is, like, what evils would help us, like, aura farm really hard, you know? And then these tend to be, like, capabilities that you yourself think are really impressive. Yeah. Like, like, what do I think is at the limits of my capabilities? And if I can get our next release to do those things, you know,
我向同事解释这一点的方式是，什么样的评估会帮助我们，光环农场非常努力，你知道吗？这些往往是你自己认为非常令人印象深刻的能力。是的。比如，我认为我的能力极限在哪里？如果我能让我们的下一个版本做这些事情，你知道，
then I think I'd be really, really proud of the work we did. Yeah. You know, another, the last point I'll touch on before I let everybody go and I'll go to sleep. You know, Connor, you mentioned earlier that like,
那么我想我会为我们所做的工作感到非常非常自豪。是的。你知道，另一个，在我让大家离开并去睡觉之前我要触及的最后一点。你知道，Connor，你之前提到过，
like the stuff you were doing, you know, like I stopped it because it wasn't valuable. And I, I just keep coming across places in which the usage data, that like the experimentation, like the,
就像你正在做的事情，你知道，我停止了它，因为它没有价值。而且，我不断遇到使用数据的地方，就像实验，就像，
the, the history of what has been tried is just so valuable. It's valuable for like one learning, like, you can analyze it, you can improve things, you can analyze how particular tools or frameworks are used. And like, once you have data at scale, like, you can learn a lot from that. It's, it's valuable for like simulating how, you know, how these long horizon tasks work, which can tell us a lot about how various frameworks and hardware might perform. And then it can be valuable for training models, for doing post-training and R.L. And it can be valuable for extracting, like, oh, like, maybe this is something that would be a good, you know, a good benchmark.
尝试过的历史是如此有价值。它对于学习很有价值，你可以分析它，你可以改进事物，你可以分析特定的工具或框架是如何使用的。而且，一旦你有了规模化的数据，你就可以从中学习很多。它对于模拟这些长远任务是如何工作的很有价值，这可以告诉我们很多关于各种框架和硬件可能如何表现的信息。然后它对于训练模型、进行后期训练和强化学习很有价值。而且它对于提取很有价值，比如，哦，也许这是一个好的基准测试。
And I just, I think there's so much value in all this data. And like, that's one of the things I think is great about GPU mode is it's just, it's this, you know, it's this farm that's producing all of this super high value data, like open data that can all benefit from. I mean, Bryce, honestly, to me, it seems like the more you're talking, the more I get excited about this idea of like, why don't we just make it easier for people to compete in our competitions using open model tokens?
而且我只是，我认为所有这些数据中都有太多的价值。而且，我认为 GPU 模式的一大优点是它只是，它是一个农场，正在产生所有这些超高价值的数据，每个人都可以从中受益的开放数据。我的意思是，Bryce，老实说，对我来说，你说的越多，我就越对这个想法感到兴奋，比如，为什么我们不让人们更容易地使用开放模型代币来参加我们的比赛呢？
We can subsidize the tokens by picking the problems to be the kernels that show up in the open models. And we get this like nice recursive self-improvement loop with people doing, search over the best prompts collectively, because I think that's highly not obvious. For these sprints over the weekend, the Connor is definitely going to have to cut this part out. Because it was like advertised as like, come like we're going to do agentic engineering on this hard problem,
我们可以通过选择出现在开放模型中的内核作为问题来补贴代币。我们得到了这个很好的递归自我改进循环，人们集体对最佳提示进行搜索，因为我认为这非常不明显。对于周末的这些冲刺，Connor 肯定必须剪掉这一部分。因为它被宣传为，来吧，我们要在这个难题上进行智能体工程，
like they didn't have to learn anything about Kuta first. What they did was they had to learn how to set up auto research. And then like on the second day, once they'd produce some auto research results, then like we like sat down and I, talked to them about the problem and taught them a bit about GPU architecture and like they were able to learn more because they'd already accomplished something. They didn't know what they'd accomplished yet because the agent had accomplished before them. Yeah, but but but they got like that
他们不必先学习任何关于 CUDA 的知识。他们所做的是他们必须学习如何设置自动研究。然后，在第二天，一旦他们产生了一些自动研究结果，那么我们就坐下来，我与他们讨论了这个问题，并教了他们一些关于 GPU 架构的知识，他们能够学到更多，因为他们已经完成了一些事情。他们还不知道他们完成了什么，因为智能体在他们之前已经完成了。是的，但他们得到了那种
sort of first like dopamine rush right. Like I made something faster. Definitely like one thing. I have this vision for like in the future of like doing I guess the way I know you said you weren't such a fan of like in person events but I'm imagining like GTC auto research academy where like you just like you have two hours every day where you come you give everybody unlimited inference for the week you come in for two hours every day and it's like a study group because you know you're like in between the study group meetings people are going and running stuff and producing results and then you come back and you check in and yeah i think it'd be i i think it'd be very valuable to have open tokens and i think people position open tokens as a public good is like this idea of like oh it's like it's good
第一种多巴胺冲动，对吧。我让某样东西变快了。绝对是这样。我有一个愿景，比如在未来，做，我猜我知道你说你不是那种面对面活动的粉丝，但我正在想象，比如 GTC 自动研究学院，你每天有两个小时，你来，你给每个人一周的无限推理，你每天来两个小时，这就像一个学习小组，因为你知道，你在学习小组会议之间，人们正在去运行东西并产生结果，然后你回来并签到，是的，我认为拥有开放代币会非常有价值，而且我认为人们将开放代币定位为公共产品，就像这种想法，哦，它很好
But for me, it seems like it's insanely valuable to Invidia to do this. Yeah, like, basically, just to sort of be specific on the, like, I think my take on events these days is just like the agentic era has made open-ended judging a bit cooked because it's like, how do you tell whether something is amazing versus not if it's just like if Claude one shot it? But if someone did a hill climb on a task that we can all collectively agree on is hard and made it. like a breakthrough. That's better than what I would do myself as an advanced user. Like, if they can just do that during the Akathon, like I'm very impressed. And so like,
但对我来说，Nvidia 做这件事似乎非常有价值。是的，基本上，只是具体说明一下，我认为如今我对活动的看法是，智能体时代让开放式评判变得有点复杂，因为如果 Claude 一次性就完成了，你怎么判断某件事是好是坏？但如果有人针对我们公认的难题进行了爬山算法并取得了突破。那比我作为一个高级用户自己做的要好。如果他们能在黑客松期间做到这一点，我会非常佩服。所以，
it just doesn't matter how they did it. It what matters is the output. So I think that I'm very open to. And I think it's going to become a lot more interesting doing it with open models this year because like the open models are good finally at these tests. I think it looks like they've been RLed on kernel data. And so I think it's going to be a lot more exciting than it was like a year ago. I want to pitch you on another idea I had,
这并不重要，重要的是产出。所以我对此持非常开放的态度。而且我认为今年使用开源模型来做这件事会变得更有趣，因为开源模型终于在这些测试中表现出色了。我认为看起来它们已经在内核数据上进行了强化学习。所以我认为这会比一年前令人兴奋得多。我想向你推销我有的另一个想法，
which is, you know, you talked about the idea of having like a package, like, here's how to deploy a, you know, like an inference service to do this, like at your company. I've been thinking about this idea, well, you know, what we want to do is we need to, we need GPs for two things. We need GPs one to run the tests and the benchmarks. And two, we need GPUs to run the inference. And, you know, there's, like, web search is something that, like, runs, like, inference, like, you know, on the inference provider's side. Like, why couldn't we have, like, a, you know, inference provider side, like, tool call that just like, like, like, that's like
那就是，你知道，你谈到了拥有一个包的想法，比如，这是如何在你的公司部署推理服务的方法。我一直在思考这个想法，好吧，你知道，我们想做的是我们需要 GPU 来做两件事。我们需要 GPU 来运行测试和基准测试。第二，我们需要 GPU 来运行推理。而且，你知道，网络搜索是某种运行推理的东西，比如，在推理提供商的一侧。为什么我们不能有一个推理提供商一侧的工具调用，它只是
modal that just like runs the serverless thing there. And then like, if you're a company and you have like, you know, an 8XB200 machine, it can both run your inference and run your serverless, you know, e-vals. Because a lot of people seem gated on the GPU access to. Yeah, I think of these is like very related problems. It's just like, like, I would imagine more people would know what to do with tokens versus a GPU. So it's like, I would imagine like broader market appeal. Yeah. I mean, like, ultimately, I think the way
Modal，它只是在那里运行无服务器的东西。然后，如果你是一家公司，你有一台 8XB200 机器，它既可以运行你的推理，也可以运行你的无服务器评估。因为很多人似乎被 GPU 访问权限所限制。是的，我认为这些是非常相关的问题。这就像，我想象更多的人会知道如何处理代币而不是 GPU。所以这就像，我想象更广泛的市场吸引力。是的。我的意思是，最终，我认为
modal set up how you acquire GPU, I think this is the correct way to do it because it's very incentive aligned with your customers to charge per use. Like, it's an honest business. Basically, as the way I would frame it. And I think paying for access is dishonest because it's, I just, yeah,
Modal 设置你如何获取 GPU 的方式，我认为这是正确的方法，因为它与你的客户非常激励一致，按使用量收费。这是一家诚实的生意。基本上，这就是我会构建它的方式。而且我认为支付访问费用是不诚实的，因为，我只是，是的，
like, because whether you use it or not, it's like, it's not great. I don't like it. Yeah. Yeah, it's like, if I could, like, my biggest thing within Nvidia right now is like, I need, like, I have this, stream of like free tokens from breath.
因为无论你是否使用它，它都不太好。我不喜欢它。是的。是的，就像，如果我可以，就像，我现在在 Nvidia 内部最大的事情是，我需要，我有这个来自 Breath 的免费代币流。
I just, if they could just make a serverless product, even if it's like a worst version of modal, then like I would not need to ask for as many tokens. And like, it could be so much more token efficient. By the way, I refreshed the, I refreshed the tokens for the profiling service again too.
如果他们能制作一个无服务器产品，即使它是一个更糟糕的 Modal 版本，那么我就不需要要求那么多的代币了。而且，它可以更节省代币。顺便说一下，我也再次刷新了分析服务的代币。
Thank you, sir. Yeah. So I think there's enough in there to run through, to run through the end of July. But so when, how long does the optimizer contest run? the optimizer we don't know yet but we're thinking of making it run for a month okay i'm just going to keep refreshing the tokens for the profiling service until somebody tells me to stop okay that's that's wonderful yeah yeah i think we didn't get the chance to talk much about the optimizer competition but
谢谢你，先生。是的。所以我认为里面有足够的东西可以运行到 7 月底。但是，优化器比赛运行多长时间？优化器我们还不知道，但我们正在考虑让它运行一个月。好的，我只是要一直刷新分析服务的代币，直到有人告诉我停止。好的，那太棒了。是的，我想我们没有机会谈论优化器比赛，但是
i think it's pretty it's pretty sick actually yeah i'll tell you more about it next time yeah i'm very excited i started looking into it yeah it looks like it's going to be very cool okay do you mind if i just tell you about it for a bit yeah i think just okay so so the optimizer competition The sort of main idea was that we've been very interested in picking tasks where transformers obviously fall flat on their face. And so the task we picked is one that involves depth. It's basically like repeated squaring and modulo. You try to make any like the largest transformers run a wall on this task. It's going to run flat on.
我认为它实际上非常酷。是的，下次我会告诉你更多。是的，我非常兴奋，我开始研究它了。看起来它会非常酷。好的，你介意我给你讲讲吗？是的，我想只是好的，所以优化器比赛的主要想法是我们一直对选择 Transformer 显然会失败的任务非常感兴趣。所以我们选择的任务是涉及深度的任务。它基本上就像重复平方和模运算。你试图让任何最大的 Transformer 在这个任务上运行。它会失败的。
It's going to fall flat on his face and it's going to try and cheat the task. And intrinsically, the only models that have like the right inductive biases to solve these problems are those that include like basically some form of looping. or adaptive depth, or like basically, and they basically involve like scaling training time compute to sort of like solve the task. And these are very exciting because if you sort of, if you maybe have a brief physics background, like a lot of these,
它会失败，并且会试图欺骗任务。本质上，只有具有解决这些问题的正确归纳偏置的模型才是那些包含某种形式循环的模型。或者自适应深度，或者基本上，它们基本上涉及扩展训练时间计算来解决任务。这些非常令人兴奋，因为如果你，如果你也许有短暂的物理背景，像很多这些，
like anything that involves looping becomes like basically, it turns into mush, like basically, it just goes either to zeros or it goes to nan. Like the systems become very unstable. And so what we're very excited about here is we want people to come up with interesting like model architecture ideas to solve this very like, simply formulated but very nasty problem.
任何涉及循环的东西都会变成基本上，它变成了糊状物，基本上，它要么变成零，要么变成 NaN。系统变得非常不稳定。所以我们在这里非常兴奋的是，我们希望人们想出有趣的模型架构想法来解决这个非常简单但非常令人讨厌的问题。
But because these architectures are quite unstable, they will also need to come up with sophisticated optimizers to solve this problem. And the sort of user experience we borrowed is the exact same as kernel bot. It's like you submit a single Python file and we run all of these evaluations for you. Right now we're basically going through like a trial period
但因为这些架构非常不稳定，他们还需要想出复杂的优化器来解决这个问题。我们借用的用户体验与内核机器人完全相同。就像你提交一个单一的 Python 文件，我们为你运行所有这些评估。现在我们基本上正在经历一个试用期
where people are reward hacking us to death, which is okay. It helps us like have the rules be more robust. We're going to launch for real this Thursday. and the competition will be open for about a month and we're kind of excited to sort of see who comes out of the woodworks here. What's been interesting is that there's just like,
人们正在奖励黑客攻击我们，这没关系。它帮助我们让规则更稳健。我们将在本周四正式发布。比赛将开放大约一个月，我们有点兴奋地看到谁会从这里脱颖而出。有趣的是，这里只是，
you know, there's like, it's sort of this interesting intersection between people that do complexity theory and model architecture where they will write very specific proofs as to things like, hey, like a diffusion model can't actually learn long sequence
你知道，这就像，这是做复杂性理论和模型架构的人之间有趣的交叉点，他们会写出非常具体的证明，比如，嘿，扩散模型实际上无法学习长序列
like video generation. And I find this like to be really, really compelling and I just can't wait to see what people do. Generally for me, I think GPU mode really becomes healthier if people are aware of like frontier level problems. And this is like a frontier level problem that I think many, many people are interested in. So I think we made it very agent friendly.
比如视频生成。我发现这非常非常引人注目，我迫不及待地想看看人们会做什么。总的来说，我认为如果人们意识到前沿水平的问题，GPU 模式确实会变得更健康。这是一个前沿水平的问题，我认为许多许多人都感兴趣。所以我认为我们让它对智能体非常友好。
The GPUs are all free. You get an hour of training time basically a day. So, you know, please have fun. The website is like one layer deeper.aI. And I think it's going to be like one of our most interesting challenges yet. And I'm very excited about it. Yeah. No, I think it's not being not being an ML person.
GPU 都是免费的。你基本上每天有一个小时的训练时间。所以，请玩得开心。网站是 deeper.ai。而且我认为这将是我们迄今为止最有趣的挑战之一。我对此感到非常兴奋。是的。不，我认为它不是，不是一个 ML 人。
I like being more a kernel person than an ML person It's a little out of my depth But from what I've read up on it It looks like it's a very cool problem And I'm very excited to see what people will Will be able to do with it And it also seems like it's something that is probably not in the training set And is like a frontier problem that will really be able to see
我更喜欢做一个内核人而不是 ML 人。这有点超出了我的能力范围。但从我读到的内容来看，它看起来是一个非常酷的问题，我非常兴奋地看到人们将能够用它做什么。而且它看起来也像是一个可能不在训练集中的东西，是一个前沿问题，我们将真正能够看到
What people can do with auto research for this Yeah Yeah All right one last one last question And it hopefully will be a short one because I know Bryce, you need to go to sleep because you're over in the Europe's. One of my, it's not really a hobby, but something I've been doing over the last several months is I, well, the details don't matter, but I listen to a lot of, no, no, tell us the details.
人们可以用自动研究做什么。是的。是的。好的，最后一个问题。希望这是一个简短的问题，因为我知道 Bryce，你需要去睡觉，因为你在欧洲。我的一个，这并不是真正的爱好，但我过去几个月一直在做的事情是，我，好吧，细节不重要，但我听了很多，不，不，告诉我们细节。
The details, all right, very quickly. I mean, I have a vibe-coded podcast player called Podgod, which was going to get released in the next couple weeks. But I've been using it since the beginning of February and it's phenomenal. One of the things that allows you to do is it allows you to follow personalities. So there's something called a personality meta podcast, which is just a curated feed of every single time that person goes on a different podcast because there are some people that I care about and I want to listen to any time they're being interviewed. But I don't want to have to go and listen.
细节，好的，非常快。我的意思是，我有一个 vibe-coded 播客播放器叫 Podgod，它将在接下来的几周内发布。但我从二月初就开始使用它了，它非常棒。它允许你做的一件事是它允许你关注个性。所以有一个叫个性元播客的东西，这只是那个人每次去不同播客的精选提要，因为有一些我关心的人，我想在他们被采访时听。但我不想去听。
Give an example. The person that I'm about to mention is Boris Churney. But the thing is, one, I don't know who that is. What? The creator of Claude Code? No, no idea. That's very sad. He's like, he's honestly would be my number one pick to have as.
举个例子。我即将提到的那个人是 Boris Churney。但问题是，第一，我不知道那是谁。什么？Claude Code 的创造者？不，不知道。那太可悲了。他就像，他老实说会是我作为嘉宾的首选。
like a future guest because every every time he is interviewed I think he has just like amazing takes but anyway so like there's a bunch of podcasts that one I don't want to subscribe to like there's like Sequoia has this like kind of there's a bunch of these like VC money podcasts but every once in a while they have someone interesting on so like I don't want to have to subscribe to this and then like basically just like download the thing and then delete it I just want the interviews anyways that's that's not long story short that's long story long whenever you to Boris Churney, like one out of every two podcasts, he gets like book recommendations, or he gives book recommendations. And they've been phenomenal. The first one that he recommended,
就像未来的嘉宾一样，因为每次采访他，我都觉得他的观点非常精彩。总之，有很多播客我不想订阅，比如红杉资本（Sequoia）的那种，有很多这类风险投资相关的播客，但偶尔会有一些有趣的人上节目，所以我不想为了听一期节目就去订阅，然后下载完再删除，我只想听采访。长话短说，或者说长话长说，每隔一期播客，Boris Churney 就会推荐书籍，或者他会给出书单。这些推荐都非常棒。他推荐的第一本书，
he actually mentioned in the Peter Man podcast, which is like a former, I think, Instagram or Facebook guy. And he's just been, it's great interviews. He interviewed Boris Churney. And then he mentions that during the interview for Anthropic, he ended up talking about some book by Greg Egan. You know, this is back in like Claude, I don't know, 3.7, 4.0 days. I immediately go to like whatever, chat chit, ask, like, what book is he referring to? And it ended up being permutation city. And that is like part of a trilogy that has diaspora and Schildschild. He, on a more recent podcast, mentioned Werner Vinges, A Fire Upon the Deep, which is in the Zones of Thought trilogy.
他实际上是在 Peter Man 的播客里提到的，那个人好像以前在 Instagram 或 Facebook 工作。他的采访做得非常棒。他采访了 Boris Churney，在采访中提到他在 Anthropic 工作期间，最终谈到了 Greg Egan 的某本书。你知道，那还是 Claude 3.7 或 4.0 刚出来的时候。我立刻去问聊天机器人，他指的是哪本书？结果是《置换城市》（Permutation City）。那是三部曲的一部分，另外两部是《离散》（Diaspora）和《盾》（Schild's Ladder）。在最近的一期播客中，他提到了 Werner Vinge 的《深渊上的火》（A Fire Upon the Deep），那是《思想区域》（Zones of Thought）三部曲中的一本。
I'm like one down, two to go. I bring all of this up. Where's the question to ask you? So you wrote the robot overlord manual. and you're the first person actually that we've interviewed on this podcast, which is a little bit surprising. That is as high on AI as Bryce and I. We've interviewed some folks over the last little bit, but not like, not people that are sipping the Kool-Aid as much as we are. And so the answer to this question may be I don't have any recommendations.
我心想，读完一本，还有两本。我提起这些是为了什么呢？我要问你的问题是什么？你写了《机器人霸主手册》（Robot Overlord Manual），而且你是我们在这个播客中采访的第一位对人工智能如此热衷的嘉宾，这有点令人惊讶。Bryce 和我一样，我们最近采访了一些人，但没有像我们这样如此沉迷其中的。所以这个问题的答案可能是：我没有任何推荐。
My question is, do you have any book recommendations in general? And on top of that, specifically, I would love to know if you have, like, any recommendations in the space of, you know, future AI, like good, these kinds of good reads that, like, people like Boris Churny recommending. So over to you. Yeah, like, I mean, I love reading. Like, these are all my books. The listener can't see, but there's also, like, a bookshelf in the background with what looks like at least a couple hundred books there. So there's, like, a couple of other hundred that I've given away over the years.
我的问题是，你有什么书可以推荐吗？此外，我特别想知道，在未来人工智能领域，你有没有像 Boris Churney 推荐的那种好书？所以，交给你了。是的，我非常喜欢阅读。这些都是我的书。听众看不到，但我背景里的书架上至少有几百本书。还有几百本是我这些年来送人的。
But, yeah, I mean, I, like, I actually, like, I do, I had a tweet about this, which is, like, my 10 favorite books. Let me see. So I would say on the AAAA, like, okay, so these are the books that are most influential to me. There's 10 of them. So let me see. Maybe I can pick two for you. Well, we'll include the link to the tweet so you can get all 10. And feel free to just read all 10 off if you want.
但是，是的，我确实发过一条关于我最喜欢的 10 本书的推文。让我看看。我认为对我影响最大的书有 10 本。让我看看能不能为你挑两本。我们会附上推文链接，这样你就能看到全部 10 本书了。如果你想的话，也可以把这 10 本书都读一遍。
Okay. It's a more interesting question. Okay. All 10. So my, like, the book that I think was like the most fun to me was a book called The Journey to the Ants. So it's a book about like ant-based intelligence. And the reason why I found it very interesting is because, like, the kinds of shit ants can do is pretty wild.
好的。这是一个更有趣的问题。好的，全部 10 本。对我来说，我觉得最有趣的一本书叫《蚂蚁的旅程》（The Journey to the Ants）。这是一本关于蚂蚁智能的书。我发现它非常有趣的原因是，蚂蚁能做的事情简直太疯狂了。
Like, for instance, like, you can have, like, the mother aunt, the queen, like, control the gender ratio of a population, control, like, people's tasks. Like, you can be a worker versus a warrior elastically based on the demands of the colony. And they all sort of spread this message between each other to sort of dictate. This is very contrary to how, like, human societies operate, where we're like, oh, I'm a colonel guy, and I will never not do colonels. Like, we're very inelastic. So it's like pretty remarkable for me to see an example of societies that were not this way.
例如，蚁后可以控制种群的性别比例，控制成员的任务。你可以根据蚁群的需求，灵活地在工蚁和兵蚁之间转换。它们之间会传播这种信息来下达指令。这与人类社会的运作方式截然不同，我们通常会说，哦，我是做内核的，我永远只会做内核。我们非常缺乏弹性。所以，看到一个不是这样的社会例子，对我来说非常了不起。
And I think this book is wonderful. Another book I really love is visual group theory. So visual group theory and maybe I would add Burns Euclid here. What I found really lovely about these books is that like anything that's algebraic tends to be like very dry and like kind of unintuitive to read because you just see look at these long formulas. Both of these books are pretty like beautiful. They almost feel like pieces of art where people are sort of like going through like these arguments like very rigorously. And so for me, they really made me appreciate the idea of a beautiful explanation, which is like typically when I think of like my job,
我觉得这本书太棒了。我喜欢的另一本书是《视觉群论》（Visual Group Theory）。所以《视觉群论》，也许我还会加上伯恩的《欧几里得》（Burn's Euclid）。我发现这些书非常可爱的地方在于，任何代数相关的东西往往都很枯燥，读起来很不直观，因为你只会看到长长的公式。这两本书都非常美。它们几乎感觉像是艺术品，人们以非常严谨的方式推导论证。所以对我来说，它们让我真正欣赏到了“优美的解释”这一概念，这通常是我认为我的工作所在，
I don't necessarily think of it as like producing like beautiful code or fast code. I think of it as being able to produce a good explanation for why the code is fast. Like that's kind of almost like my love language. Another book I've adored is the theory of fun. So the theory of fun is a book on why people like playing games. It's sort of like the sort of the main thesis of the book is that playing is basically the way we learn. So I've carried that a lot into my projects where I've tried to make a lot of the things
我不一定认为我的工作是编写优美的代码或快速的代码。我认为我的工作是能够对代码为何快速做出好的解释。这几乎是我的“爱的语言”。我非常喜欢的另一本书是《乐趣的理论》（The Theory of Fun）。《乐趣的理论》是一本关于人们为什么喜欢玩游戏的书。这本书的主要论点是，玩耍基本上是我们学习的方式。所以我把这一点带入了很多项目中，我尝试让很多事情
we've done with GPU mode fun and as a result, people end up learning more and might find it more valuable. So a lot of what I learned with GPU mode was basically early days of playing world of Warcraft and Workraft 3. So a lot of the lessons, funnily enough, do you apply? I would say two technical books that I've,
我们用 GPU 模式（GPU Mode）做的事情变得有趣，结果人们学到了更多，也觉得更有价值。所以我在 GPU 模式中学到的很多东西，基本上就是早期玩《魔兽世界》和《魔兽争霸 3》的经验。有趣的是，很多经验确实适用。我想说有两本技术书，我，
I think I'm going to skip over a couple of books, but two technical books that I think I highly recommend to everyone are game programming patterns and working with legacy code. Working with legacy code often surprise. rises people as one of my favorite books of all time. But I found it really wonderful when I'm just like plopped into like a monstrous code base, how do you sort of like quickly make sense of it? And like what are good design patterns to make codes like simpler and easier to reason about?
我想跳过几本书，但我强烈推荐给每个人的两本技术书是《游戏编程模式》（Game Programming Patterns）和《重构：改善既有代码的设计》（Working Effectively with Legacy Code）。《重构》这本书经常让人们感到惊讶，它是我有史以来最喜欢的书之一。但我发现，当我被扔进一个庞大的代码库时，如何快速理解它，以及什么是让代码更简单、更易于推理的良好设计模式，这非常棒。
I think a lot of like my contributions in the past projects has been like going into a complicated code base and like understanding it and then figuring out how to develop features more quickly on top. I think a lot of these ideas will make a comeback if we're like basically in mountains of slop. Maybe yet another book that I've really enjoyed. Maybe maybe I'll give you two more. Like game theoretic foundations for probability and finance. It's not a finance book, even though it's in the title. It's a book about rewriting all the axiom of probability theory with game theory
我认为我在过去项目中的很多贡献，就是进入一个复杂的代码库，理解它，然后弄清楚如何在上面更快地开发功能。我认为如果我们陷入一堆烂代码中，很多这些想法会卷土重来。也许我再给你推荐两本我非常喜欢的书。《概率与金融的博弈论基础》（Game-Theoretic Foundations for Probability and Finance）。这不是一本金融书，尽管标题里有。这是一本用博弈论重写概率论所有公理的书，
in a way that makes them a lot more interpretable. And so I've also really enjoyed this kind of book because I've always enjoyed more wacky math. It just can help you build intuition. And if you didn't have like one notation, maybe you'll appreciate another. The last one is the structure and interpretation of classical mechanics. I'm sure many of you might have read the structure interpretation of computer programs. I thought that's what I thought you were going to say. I think this book is better because it basically goes over, like, it's right short programs
它让这些公理变得更加可解释。我也非常喜欢这类书，因为我一直喜欢更古怪的数学。它能帮助你建立直觉。如果你不喜欢一种符号，也许你会欣赏另一种。最后一本是《经典力学的结构与解释》（The Structure and Interpretation of Classical Mechanics）。我相信你们很多人可能读过《计算机程序的构造和解释》（SICP）。我以为你会说那本。我觉得这本书更好，因为它基本上是关于，用 LISP 编写的物理短程序，
for physics written in LISP, and you basically end up with nature as like a short series of self-modifying LISP programs. It's one of those like books that like blow your mind the first time you read it. But like, again, like as we get into the age of auto research and architecture research, I suspect a lot of these ideas are making a big comeback. So these are things that I think are, you know, there's a lot more, but like maybe, you know, berserk and Necronomicon, maybe some pieces of fiction that I think are just like absolutely gorgeous. I've always been a sucker for like, there's some piece of knowledge that if you acquire it,
你最终会发现自然界就像一系列简短的自修改 LISP 程序。这是那种你第一次读时会让你大开眼界的书。但是，随着我们进入自动研究和架构研究的时代，我怀疑很多这些想法正在卷土重来。所以这些是我认为，当然还有很多，但也许，你知道，《剑风传奇》（Berserk）和《死灵之书》（Necronomicon），也许还有一些我认为绝对华丽的虚构作品。我一直对那种“如果你获得了某种知识，你就会发疯”的情节毫无抵抗力。
I don't know, you'll blow up because you'll be rendered mad. I don't know why, but it's like one of those things that I've always been like a sucker for this kind of like fantasy work. But yeah, all these books are phenomenal. And I'll share the full list if you like with you in a few minutes. But yeah, I think these are sufficiently out of distribution to give you better ideas. I mean, I feel bad we haven't asked our other past guests because that was amazing. Even better than, not that I had expectations for the quality of your answer, but even better than I expected.
我不知道为什么，但这一直是我喜欢的那种奇幻作品。总之，所有这些书都很棒。如果你愿意，几分钟后我会和你分享完整的书单。但我觉得这些书足够“离群”，能给你提供更好的思路。说实话，没问我们之前的嘉宾我感到很抱歉，因为这太棒了。甚至比我预期的还要好，并不是说我对你的回答质量有什么预设，但确实比我预期的还要好。
Go ahead, Bryce. I have a related question, which is, it sounds like, it sounds like you have been a person who's played a lot of video games in the past. I'm wondering if you have recommendations for video games. Let me see. So what are the greatest games I've played? So one of the issues with like, I think the greatest game I've ever played is probably Dota 2, but I would not recommend you play it because it just will take over your life. So I think it's like an optimizer's dream in some sense and it teaches you how to never get mad
继续吧，Bryce。我有一个相关的问题，听起来你过去玩过很多电子游戏。我想知道你有没有什么电子游戏推荐？让我看看。我玩过的最伟大的游戏是什么？我认为我玩过的最伟大的游戏可能是《Dota 2》，但我不会建议你去玩，因为它会占据你的生活。在某种意义上，它是优化者的梦想，它教会你如何永远不对任何事情生气，
at anything because like it's very formative to be insulted at in like five different languages and still manage how to win a game. So it's very formative. But I would say like, I mean, if I'm thinking like games, that left like a deep impression on me. I would say recently, I would probably say it was like, Expedition 33 as like sort of a story-based game
因为在五种不同的语言中被辱骂，却依然能设法赢得比赛，这非常有塑造力。所以这非常有意义。但如果说让我印象深刻的游戏，最近的话，我可能会说是《远征 33》（Expedition 33），作为一种故事驱动的游戏，
like really left like a deep impression on me and I was like a big sucker for like role-playing games like growing up, you know, all the way ranging from like Pokemon to like Chrono Trigger. As a result, I've also really enjoyed Final Fantasy 16 recently. I've been playing Final Fantasy 7 as well, which I really enjoy. But yeah, otherwise, like these days, like I mostly spent a lot of time playing Slay the Spire,
它给我留下了深刻的印象。我从小就非常喜欢角色扮演游戏，从《宝可梦》到《时空之轮》（Chrono Trigger）。因此，我最近也非常喜欢《最终幻想 16》。我也在玩《最终幻想 7》，我也很喜欢。但除此之外，这些天我大部分时间都在玩《杀戮尖塔》（Slay the Spire），
but I also feel like I spent too much time doing it. If you give me an optimization puzzle, usually I can get obsessed with it. If you give me something that's fast and reflex-based, like Fury or Katana Zero, I'm also like a big sucker for those. I enjoy sort of this like flow feeling. And I think these are all games that will give you like a major, major sense of flow. So they're all treats if you haven't played them. So my actually, my oldest friend, the person that I've had the longest contact with,
但我也觉得我花在上面的时间太多了。如果你给我一个优化谜题，我通常会沉迷其中。如果你给我一些快速、基于反应的游戏，比如《Furi》或《武士零》（Katana Zero），我也非常喜欢。我享受那种“心流”的感觉。我认为这些游戏都能给你带来极大的心流感。所以如果你还没玩过，它们都是好东西。其实，我最老的朋友，我联系时间最长的人，
is somebody I've never actually met in person. And he and I, I used to play a lot of muds, based games when I was a kid, and he and I played muds together. And in particular, my favorite type of mud was a role-play intensive mud, so that's where everybody has to be in character at all times. I primarily played either Star Wars or Lord of the Rings themed muds. And these were all like community run, multiplayer games, and nobody was really concerned about the fact that Star Wars and Lord of the Rings were IP that somebody else owned. But anyways, him and I were having this conversation the other day where it's a text-based game. Like,
是一个我从未在现实中见过面的人。小时候我们经常玩 MUD（多用户地下城）游戏，我们一起玩。特别是我最喜欢的 MUD 类型是重度角色扮演 MUD，每个人都必须时刻保持角色状态。我主要玩《星球大战》或《指环王》主题的 MUD。这些都是社区运营的多人游戏，没人关心《星球大战》和《指环王》是别人的知识产权。总之，前几天我们还在讨论，这是一种基于文本的游戏，
It is, you could just like hook up, I'm sure, like a frontier model to it. And, you know, the problem of these games have today is like, you know, the NPCs are not particularly good and there's just not a lot of players. And him and I were talking about like, well, we could just make as many players as we want. You know, you could just like, you wouldn't even need to code them into the game. You could just connect an existing agent to an existing mud and just have it interact the game as it would any other player character. And I just like, I haven't been able to get this idea out of my head. and if I had more infinite inference, I would go build my like AI mud game
你可以连接一个前沿模型到它上面。这些游戏今天的问题是 NPC 不太聪明，玩家也不多。我们当时在讨论，我们可以制造尽可能多的玩家。你甚至不需要把它们写进游戏代码里，你只需要把一个现有的智能体连接到一个现有的 MUD，让它像其他玩家角色一样与游戏互动。我一直无法把这个想法从脑海中抹去。如果我有无限的推理能力，我一定会去构建我的 AI MUD 游戏，
and I'm sure I'd have a blast with it. I think we should try it out because I think one hybrid idea I'd be very optimistic about would be something like an in-person Dungeons and Dragons game. Oh, yes. Like where the DM can basically choose to
我相信我会玩得很开心。我觉得我们应该尝试一下，因为我觉得一个我非常看好的混合想法是类似线下的《龙与地下城》（Dungeons and Dragons）游戏。哦，是的。DM（地下城主）基本上可以选择，
like basically where there's a DM who's constantly prompting to try and anticipate where like things might go. That I'm really optimistic about. But I think a lot of the, I think issues I foresee with current alums is like post-compaction, maybe they'll lose everything. Like, they'll have no idea what the fuck's going on the game. We should do a whole, we should talk some other time about my thoughts on compa.
基本上有一个 DM 在不断地提示，试图预判事情的发展方向。我对这一点非常看好。但我认为目前大语言模型（LLM）存在的问题是，压缩之后，它们可能会丢失一切。它们会完全不知道游戏里发生了什么。我们应该找个时间专门谈谈我对压缩的想法。
I think sometimes compaction helps and sometimes it hurts in the short. Yeah. The thing that's most valuable that I get, that happens at compaction is most harnesses on compaction will reread skills. And that can sometimes help because then it's like a reminder of like, were you following were you following like the prompts and skills that you were originally given? Anyways, I should go. It's getting very late here and we should let Mark get going.
我觉得有时压缩有帮助，有时在短期内会有害。是的。压缩过程中最有价值的事情是，大多数压缩方案会重新读取技能。这有时会有帮助，因为它像是一种提醒：你是否遵循了最初给你的提示和技能？总之，我该走了。这里已经很晚了，我们应该让 Mark 走了。
Good night, Bryce. And thank you for inviting me, Bryce. It was a pleasure to chat with you. Be sure to check these show notes, either in your podcast app or at ADSP thepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a get-up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day.
晚安，Bryce。谢谢你的邀请，Bryce。和你聊天很愉快。请务必查看节目说明，无论是在你的播客应用中还是在 ADSPthepodcast.com 上，获取我们今天提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。
Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
低质量，高数量。这就是我们播客的口号。这不是口号。我们的口号是“混乱中撒点信息”。这期节目还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。